there are a lot of weird rumors
surrounding the upcoming iPad air 4 and
I think that we finally figure them out
so in this video we're gonna break down
those rumors and discuss which features
we should expect and why Apple would
make those changes but first I want to
talk about the current status of the
iPad air 3 to be honest it's in a really
weird spot right now the 20/20 iPad pro
just came out and it offers much better
value compared to the air especially
since it gets a 128 gigabyte SSD at the
base price and on the lower end you can
get a 10.2 inch iPad for 280 dollars
right now on Amazon which comes with a
smart connector so it supports the same
great keyboard cases as the iPad air
does like the Logitech combo touch which
comes with a trackpad and a great
keyboard and of course you also have the
iPad Mini 5 for $400 if you want the
same fast chip and display features so
right now it doesn't really make sense
to buy the current iPad air compared to
the other options so with the upcoming
iPad air Apple has to make it seem worth
spending the extra cash over the budget
iPad in the iPad Mini while at the same
time it can't be so good that it
cannibalizes the sales of the $800 iPad
pro so how can Apple achieve this well
let's first take a look at some of the
rumors on this new iPad air and by the
way shout out to Talos of tech for his
excellent videos on this topic last
month we got a supply chain rumor about
a new 23 inch iMac and an 11 inch iPad
coming in the second half of this year
which is certainly talking about the
iPad air since we already got an 11 inch
iPad pro redesigned this year and then
it got weird when just a few days ago
even more rumors came suggesting a 10.8
inch iPad coming in the second half of
2020 and an iPad Mini with the larger
size display coming in next year my
first thought was maybe this 10-point 8
inch iPad is just the budget iPad with a
larger display possibly getting rid of
the home button but it just doesn't make
sense because it's meant to be as cheap
as possible and they literally just
bumped it up to a ten point two inch
display
about eight months ago so I'm sure that
this 10.8 inch iPad rumor is also
talking about the iPad air so which one
is it ten point eight or eleven well get
ready for this one we think is actually
both and let me explain why when the 11
inch 2018 iPad pro came out with a brand
new design the iPad air 3 was built with
the ipad pro's old 10.5 inch design
now what if Apple does this again
imagine the iPad air for being built
with a 2018 11 inch iPad pros design
this would mean that it would come with
support for the Apple pencil 2 in its
wireless charging feature the new modern
square edge design and the new rounded
corner display but Apple has to be very
careful because they can't make it so
good that people stop buying the iPad
pro so how can they achieve this well
instead of having an 11 inch display it
would come with a ten point eight inch
display
so both the eleven and ten point eight
is rumors would make sense at the same
time if the chassis was identical to the
iPad pro but the display itself was
slightly smaller if you think about it
the 11 inch iPad pro introduced a brand
new one point four three two one aspect
ratio so if the new iPad air maintains
the same old four by three aspect ratio
then the display size could actually be
ten point eight inches while using the
same exact metal chassis it would just
have slightly larger vessels on the top
and bottom of the display so this would
make the new ten point eight inch iPad
air look modern and appealing but the
display on the iPad pro would be slimmer
and look better
however there still needs to be some
more differences to make the iPad pro
worth the extra $300 on top of the new
iPad air so I think the air is gonna
come with the less powerful a13
processor which keep in mind is already
in every single new iphone including the
iPhone se making a cheaper since they
can mass-produce it on a higher scale
it's also not gonna have 120 Hertz
promotion display technology it's not
gonna have quad speakers it's not gonna
have the new light
scanner or the new ultra wide camera
it's not gonna have 600 nits of display
brightness and it's not gonna have
studio quality microphones all of those
features are reserved for the iPad pro
and those differences alone are gonna
make it worth spending an extra three
hundred dollars for the iPad pro if you
can afford it but at the same time the
newer square-edged design on the iPad
air is gonna make it really appealing
compared to the budget iPad options
pushing more people toward the new iPad
air now there are a few features that
I'm not totally sure about there's a
chance it'll come with face ID and
there's a chance that it'll come with a
brand new under display fingerprint
sensor and there's also a chance it'll
come with a USB C port but it might even
come with the old lightning port to
differentiate it a bit more so I'm not
completely sure about these two features
but what I do know for sure is that if
the new iPad air shares the same chassis
as the current 11 inch iPad pro then it
is a hundred percent going to support
the new magic keyboard case the reason
this makes sense for Apple is because
the keyboard case likely has very high
profit margins so even if someone spent
less money and chose the iPad air over
the pro Apple can later sell them on a
magic keyboard case and make that
difference back and if you've seen my
video on why that magic keyboard case is
Apple's master plan then you'll know
that Apple wants as many of these
keyboard cases in the hands of buyers as
possible since the magic keyboard and
its unique floating iPad design is meant
to be a symbol of the Apple brand so
there you have it we get an iPad air
that looks fresh and modern making
people want to spend more money on an
iPad purchase while also not being good
enough to cannibalize that our iPad pro
sales and the cherry on top is the magic
keyboard case support to help Apple make
some extra profit after the fact now
there are some rumors about this iPad
air getting a mini LED display but I can
almost guarantee that no iPad is getting
this display before the iPad pro gets it
first and that probably won't happen
until 2021 and then only after that we
can expect the rest of the iPad lineup
to
the new mini LED display so the whole
point of this video is that if you're
thinking about buying either the budget
iPad the iPad Mini or the iPad air
you should totally stop and wait for the
new iPad air but if you're interested in
the iPad pro go ahead and order one
right now since the iPad air is still
going to be missing a lot of the pro
features and if you do decide to go with
the pro we'll have links down below in
the description to the best deals on the
pro models so go ahead and tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]